i'm about to walk into a comic store and
that
dresses doctor stranger
just stuck there you know it's quite
nice this is great finally
yeah i absolutely need a picture i need
a picture right now may i take a picture
please
you may take a picture i think you're
taking a picture
[Music]
not resist i'm sorry this is great i
couldn't believe it
okay
okay all right we have to shoot let's go
we have to make a movie perfect this is
fantastic
thank you so much absolutely thank you
yeah all right you can always get a job
here yeah
can i if the movie doesn't work out and
bombs can i come and work with you guys
listen we could
but here's the difference we're gonna
need you to talk like an american in
this place so
yeah i'd have to do that that's fine i'm
not good with that
it's very snooty the british accent
sometimes i like you know i like playing
level much better see you guys
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is gonna be my new doctor strange two
video there's a whole bunch of new
easter eggs and we also got some more
wand division stuff to break down
easter eggs and big connections between
that series and the doctor strange two
movie
so if you're new to the channel there's
gonna be a bunch of really big stuff
happening the next couple of months
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we'll also do a new amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and let me know which
alternate versions of characters you
want to see
during doctor strange too so obviously
this video is dr strange benedict
cumberbatch
dressed in full costume just being the
coolest dude ever going into a comic
book store while they're filming the
movie
to buy a comic book and take a couple
pictures with the people inside
the comic book that the cashier hands
him that he's holding in this
picture is the oath one of the more
popular classic doctor strange stories
that re-tells
his origin story the title of the oath
is just a reference to the hippocratic
oath that he takes as a surgeon
sergeant supreme and his oath as the
sorcerer supreme
recently we found out a bunch of new
doctor strange 2 movie details from the
cast in crew and we finally got a good
look at a major crossover villain that
connects one division to doctor strange
2 while they were filming new wand
division scenes because they just
resumed production on that series
it also confirmed some major details and
really cool easter eggs from the comics
so i'll just number these as we go along
there's a bunch of really cool easter
eggs that connects everything
so a lot of you probably saw the rumors
a while ago about who the main villain
of one division was and how that would
connect to the larger multiverse
villains in doctor strange
too just because the movies tend to be
way way bigger in scale than the series
they already confirmed that one division
would be connected to doctor strange 2
with big crossover plot because scarlet
witch is going to be a main character
during the movie after
appearing in one division so one
division takes place before doctor
strange two
but outside of some early comments that
the former director scott derrickson had
made there were just a lot of theories
about nightmare
or mephisto manipulating scarlet witch
and taking advantage of her greater
reality warping chaos magic powers in
order to breach the multiverse and enter
the main
dimension of the mcu but it turns out
the villain has been standing in front
of us this whole time and i'm not
talking about scarlet witch herself
there were a lot of early theories when
people saw elizabeth olsen and the
producers teasing no more mutants house
of m easter eggs
initially people thought that that meant
that she'd be creating most of the
trouble that dr strange would have to
deal with during doctor strange too
but turns out it's way simpler than that
in the new footage from the set of wand
division confirms one of my earlier big
theories about the quote-unquote secret
characters
earlier this month we finally got a look
at katherine hans
mystery character in full comic book
costume
and does she not look like she's dressed
the exact same way that doctor strange
the ancient one
and all the other sorcerers of the
sanctum dress like she's a powerful
magic user with a really crazy looking
white hairdo
even though obviously she still appears
to be very young
early on when they released the very
first one division trailer and did the
big d23 panel catherine hahn claimed
that she'd be playing a quote-unquote
nosy neighbor that just lives near
scarlet witch and vision's house and she
wouldn't say anything else about her
character
usually that means that they're playing
a big comic book character and it'd be
some kind of spoiler if they told you
too
soon who they were playing my theory at
the time because catherine hahn is a
pretty big-name actress on television
who typically plays
morally ambiguous and really complex
characters that she would in fact be
at least one of the main villains of the
series if not the main villain
aka agatha harkness long time scarlet
witch nemesis
and mentor agatha harkness is this
ancient sorceress from the comics that
has been
both the villain and a teacher to
scarlet witch at various points
she's crazy powerful she's also a big
doctor strange comic book character
connecting both of those franchises
because remember this is important we
have to think about how one division is
connected to doctor strange too
and she's also appeared in a lot of
x-men stories because we're starting to
think about
mutants in the mcu now look at the one
division trailer and based on what
they've said about the series what
seems like is happening is when the
series starts vision is still dead
there's an important reason why they
didn't bring him back to life during
avengers end game
scarlet witch is probably still grieving
but agatha harkness
probably has something to do with
helping scarlet witch unlock
her more powerful abilities going full
comic book scarlet witch as kevin feige
said that they're taking her during the
series
i believe his statement was you will
know why she's called the scarlet witch
and agatha harkness is also probably
responsible for putting scarlet witch in
this weird alternate sitcom reality
or alternate pocket dimension where
vision is alive and they live out this
weird accelerated life through the
different sitcoms in each decade
starting in the 1950s so whatever she's
doing agatha harkness is manipulating
scarlet witch
and eventually they probably wind up
having a full-blown wizard battle
the connection to doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness is most likely
just the repercussions or consequences
of what scarlet witch is doing tearing
through different alternate realities
and dimensions
and that chaos spilling into the main
mcu dimension
remember dr strange's biggest job is
sorcerer supreme is just protecting
our reality our dimension if you're
talking about the main mcu dimension
from larger multiverse threats so if
scarlet witch were off in a pocket
reality or pocket dimension just doing
crazy things he wouldn't really care
about that unless that spilled into the
main mcu dimension
so think about it this way path to early
mutants in the mcu
reverse house of m no more mutants
easter eggs in the alternate dimension
vision is alive as we see in the trailer
even though he's a cybernetic robot
effectively through her reality warping
powers they're somehow able to conceive
her twins
from the comics wiccan and speed both
mutants talking about more x-men easter
eggs and marvel phase four
but then somehow scarlet witch finds a
way to bring them back
into the main mcu dimension with her
when she returns
blending that reality with our main
reality and that's your reverse no more
mutant scenario
and whatever the chaos they cause
because of that that's major
enough to land on doctor strange's radar
then moving into the plot of doctor
strange too
during that movie because of what
scarlet witch did altering the fabric of
the multiverse
greater multiverse villains like
nightmare or mephisto probably take
advantage of that chaos to enter the
main mcu dimension
and do even more damage on a bigger
scale that would just explain
why doctor strange would need scarlet
witch's help during his movie because
he's the most
powerful sorcerer according to the
russos and the writers of avengers end
game in the entire galaxy
but the thing is is the doctor strange
has never really met
scarlet witch officially they've never
spoken to each other there was a big
deleted scene during avengers end game a
deleted storyline
where scarlet witch and rocket were
actually going to go on a trip
together a road trip of all things to
the sanctum in new york city to try and
meet with doctor strange and get help
so maybe some of that storyline they'll
incorporate into doctor strange too
if they had already planned for them to
cross over previously
they haven't really said what's going to
happen to scarlet witch after the events
of doctor strange 2
or if she's going to come back in
avengers 5 but short-term early
predictions i think that she does
finally wind up getting a version of a
happy ending
with some version of the family that she
always wanted for herself
and the new mutant children that she
potentially rescues from the multiverse
and if she does wind up showing up
during avengers 5 they just explained
that
between those movies during those couple
years that she's just been off raising
them like a normal regular mom who just
happens to be one of the most powerful
magic users on the planet
they haven't said anything about doing a
one division season two but if they
decided to do that
maybe they cover some of her with the
children during that
marvel did say that some of the avengers
endgame spin-off disney plus series that
they've announced will get multiple
seasons and some of them will just be
one-off mini-series like tom hiddleston
already confirmed that the loki series
that they're working on right now
would get a season 2. remember that's
also a multiverse time travel series
like doctor who stuff
going on inside the mcu so there might
be some loki easter eggs during one
division doctor strange too
they'll be releasing a new one division
trailer and a new falcon and winter
soldier trailer sometime later this
month or in september so don't worry too
much about that
we're also going to get that star wars
mandalorian season 2 trailer sometime
in the next couple of weeks as well for
those of you that are waiting on new
mandalorian season 2 stuff
i'll name a new giveaway winner when i
post my next marvel video
everyone click here for that one
division trailer video in easter eggs
and click here for that new marvel
hellstrom trailer with a bunch of ghost
rider easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight